when Wright was cast as jinny in the
first film of the franchise Harry Potter
and the Sorcerer Stone in 2001 she
didn't even have any lines at all and I
didn't have a line in the script to the
point and then Chris Columbus gave me a
line on the first day so I was very
excited to suddenly be saying good luck
as Harry sort of goes through into the
platform now despite getting a line on
the spot it's clear that Jenny was not
one of those characters who got the most
focus in the film adaptations I think a
lot of the time you know the audience
didn't really ever get to see much of
jinny and I think hearing from what
people have said they've always wanted a
bit more of her of course jinny got more
opportunities to Showcase who she was as
the franchise progressed but Jenny's
character development in the film still
PED in comparison to that of the books
not that it's gossing plenty of fans
who'd been familiar with the books were
well aware of this as was Wright herself
today Wright is 32 years old and it's
been over a decade since she filmed a
movie as Jenny Weasley for the final
time